der bundesweite Probealarm ging gerade
los das bedeutet es gibt ein neues
Adventskalender Video ich habe hier ja
schon alle möglichen Adventskalender
ausgepackt und liebe es wenn es mal
wieder etwas Neues gibt was ich noch nie
gewusst habe dass es auf der Welt
existiert ein Zuckerstangen
Adventskalender und ob hier wirklich nur
Zuckerstangen drin sind und ihr mich
jetzt 24 Mal an einer Stange lutschen
seht das erfahren wir in den nächsten
Minuten ich habe den Adventskalender auf
einer Seite gekauft von der ich noch nie
gehört habe cool stuff da gibt es halt
coolen stuff wie einen Zuckerstangen
Adventskalender für 44 € 95 €
Zuckerstangen und wer hat erfunden die
Pool Kiss ich glaube so fühlen sich Amis
wenn sie Deutsch lesen
Polka
grießkocheri werden noch heute in der
gleichen Weise hergestellt wie zu Beginn
im Jahr
1859 lass uns mal durch lutschen
der Kalender ist sehr lang was ich mal
ausnahmsweise eine schöne Abwechslung
finde weil die meisten haben ja immer
die gleiche Größe aber man muss hier
nicht mehr lange suchen die Zahlen sind
einfach aneinandergeordnet nimmt es den
Spaß raus ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
aber fürs Video ist natürlich einfacher
weil einfach einfach ist ich mein
Zuckerstangen gehören einfach zu
Weihnachten dazu und manchmal hänge ich
auch welche an den Tannenbaum ich esse
sie nur nie also nie die lutscht dann da
einmal dran und merkt so ja ist halt
purer Zucker und die meisten die man so
bei Butlers oder sowas kaufen kann haben
ja nicht mal Geschmack das heißt das
sind zwar nur Zuckerstangen aber seid
ehrlich ihr fragt euch das auch gerade
wie schmeckt Türchen Nummer
okay das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so wie
es erwartet habe ich dachte da kommen
diese weihnachtliche man kennt die
klassische Sockel stand ich bin richtig
gespannt wie das jetzt aussieht
[Applaus]
ja die halten eine Zuckerstange aussehen
sollte ne Mist was auf jeden Fall gleich
auffällt ist dass sie eher matt ist und
nicht so glänzend wie die die man im
Dekoladen kaufen kann wir probieren
jetzt einfach mal ne
guck mal kurz weg
[Musik]
die schmeckt nach Minze
oder so weich
und in der Mitte hart jetzt kommt nicht
so als Experten um die Ecke hier das
gehört so auch mein Gott Minze habe ich
nicht erwartet ist aber cool ich weiß
wofür ich den benutzen werde das
erinnert mich an was und zwar wenn ihr
Gilmore Girls geschaut hat so wie ich
100 mal dann wisst ihr von dieser einen
Folge wo sie Weihnachten nachfeiern und
dann gehen sie in so einen Kaffee rein
und möchten den peppermind zuckerstand
Kaffee haben den es dann nicht mehr gibt
und die Zuckerstangen die man immer so
beim Butlers kaufen schmecken halt nur
noch Zucker die haben keinen winzigen
Geschmack und jetzt kann ich endlich
diesen peppermind Kaffee machen den sie
bei Gilmore Girls getrunken haben
und klebrig von der Verpackung sieht man
auf jeden Fall schon mal das ist so eine
richtig alte Manufaktur und so ist
richtig Tradition steckt dahinter glaub
mir oder nicht ich bin jetzt sehr
gespannt auf Türchen Nummer
okay so wird das nächste was ist denn
los mit den Türchen Kalender war es auch
schon so schwierig
ich finde den cool da steckt über 100
Jahre Tradition drin
oh das erste mal probieren hat er noch
so ein bisschen
Geschmack ist dabei
Frau geschäftlich was machen Sie
eigentlich beruflich ich
lutsche Zuckerstangen im Internet ja ist
ein Lolli perfekt okay schmeckt jetzt
wirklich nicht so wo man denkt ich bin
aber die Form lustig die Form sieht halt
so richtig aus da hat man sowas
abgeschnitten und hat man so ein Stiel
reingesteckt und das ist der Lolli
normal 3 in Nummer 3 haben wir wieder
eine Zuckerstange
EAH ich rate jetzt einfach mal das
super jetzt sind ein bisschen andere
Farbe das sieht doch cool aus
super sauer
ja ja
eigentlich ein Adventskalender für
meinen asmr-kanal werden sollen
super sauer ich finde es echt
erstaunlich dass es von außen so weich
ist und von innen so einen harten Kern
hat so ganz anders aber total lecker
also der schmeckt mir richtig gut der
schmeckt einfach so zitronig sauer nur
ich meine ich bin noch gespannt was drin
ist ich denke mal es werden zu weiteren
Zuckerstangen sein aber wenn ich jeden
Tag gesund Zucker Ding weghauen ne so
gesund ist es nicht ne Nummer vier
mein Gott es tut mir so leid Leute falls
ihr dachtet dass dieses Video gesponsert
ist muss ich euch sagen dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
Videos nicht gesponsert ich muss da
selber erstmal wieder reinkommen wisst
ihr das war eine lange Zeit jetzt
Abwechslung ein Lolli wie eben gerade
nur mit ich denke mal vielleicht
Erdbeeren Geschmack den packe ich in die
verlosungsbox Leute denn auch dieses
Jahr werde ich wieder meine Inhalte
verlosen das ist doch klar
ich weiß da jetzt wie die schmecken und
salzlakritz
weil sie nicht muss das auf salzlakritz
habe ich jetzt wirklich ganz wenig Lust
kommt in die verlosungsbox für euch
Nummer 6 es ist Nikolaus wir laufen zu
unserem Adventskalender und freuen uns
haben die Schweden nicht Nikolaus
erfunden oder waren sie Norweger Tutti
Frutti ah das erinnert mich an meinen
ersten meinen ersten Türkei Urlaub wo es
dann ein so ein Eismann gab der immer zu
uns gesagt hat Tutti Frutti very go dann
schauen wir mal ob Tutti Frutti gut ist
diese Handarbeit dieses Papierverpackung
das ist wirklich dieser Christmas spirit
weg von diesem Konsum Plastik Leuchten
alles sondern hinzu so diesen
skandinavischen Christmas Feeling das
bekommt man hier auf jeden Fall
also ich schmeckt jetzt nicht viel für
die frutti jetzt kommt aber nicht so
ganz also es ist halt so ein Kern oh so
sieht man das ganz gut bunter Kern so
eine leicht weiche außen steht das ist
hart aber nicht so intensiv geschmeckt
der hat so geschmeckt wie ich sie in
Butlers in Erinnerung habe
sieben sieben
haben wir glaube ich mittlerweile
verstanden es wechseln sich ab Lolli und
Zuckerstange
ich wollte darüber nett sein aber ich
hasse es wenn sich der Kalender nicht
schön öffnen lässt guckt euch mal an wie
das aussieht das macht auch keinen Spaß
dieses öffnungserlebnis
und jetzt schon wieder ich will das an
der Seite öffnen und dann
aufreißen in Türchen Nummer acht gibt es
Grips Krebs gut Cola Cola probieren wir
eine
Cola wow die sieht genauso aus wie die
anderen auch nur einen Geschmack mit
Cola
nee
das Karamell also das Außen schmeckt
nach Karamell aber es versucht Cola zu
sein Malzbier es schmecktürchen ja wie
Malzbier vielleicht ist eine Gerät Cola
eher so ein Malzbier oder sowas ist
jetzt nicht mein Lieblingsgeschmack aber
ihr wisstücher Nummer 9 ist das beste
Türchen und dort wird jetzt der beste
Geschmack drin sein
ein Loli ist überzeugt mich nicht ganz
ich meine es sind aber ich meine man
sieht den und man weiß irgendwie auch
schon wieder schmecken wird Nummer zehn
schade Schokolade wir haben wieder super
sauer hatten wir schon mal
sehr schade wenn sich das jetzt schon
alles wiederholt aber vielleicht
vielleicht haben wir noch Glück Nummer
11 sage ich wird wieder ein Lolli
Tutti Frutti nicht schon wieder nein
sagen wir noch mal tutti Nummer 12 nein
obwohl ja so ein Lolli hatten wir glaube
ich noch nicht so Lolli hatten wir 13
die Stange mit Pfefferminzgeschmack
schade jetzt wiederholt sich das 14 ist
es etwas
Cola ein
anderer Olli
stark nachgelassen 16 ey das ist
wirklich so unbefriedigen wie sich der
öffnen lässt ne schaut euch das mal an
das ist kompletter fledert das ist halt
nicht gut durchgestanzt das ist
Katastrophe die Leute kommen einfach
ihre Arbeit nicht nach das ist das
Problem
also die sind jetzt alle schon doppelt
wenn das jetzt schon wieder von vorne
also jetzt müsste es wieder von vorne
losgehen jetzt gab es jede Sorte schon
zweimal
Zahn haha nein 18
sogar in einer anderen Farbe eingefärbt
okay das ist ja auch überhaupt keine
Überraschung mehr außer die Lollies die
haben wahrscheinlich alle einen anderen
Geschmack probieren wir noch mal diesen
roten hier aus für den gibt's halt keine
Infos ne tutti very good
das könnte nach Bero schmecken ganz wie
Fantasien das nach vitrone also die
Lollies haben einen unterschiedlichen
Geschmack
wow salzlakritz die dritte schwarz und
pinke Strahl Türchen 24 es ist
Weihnachten und wir gehen zu unserem
Adventskalender und vielleicht haben wir
schon ein kleine Diabetes bekommen von
diesem Kalender aber wir sind trotzdem
super gespannt und freuen uns über Minze
mit Zucker ja also es gibt jeden drei
Mal ich wollte den Kalender wirklich
lieben und der Anfang hat auch richtig
Spaß gemacht dass sich das aber dreimal
wiederholt gut man muss glaube ich dafür
echten Fan sein von diesem Hersteller
und sagen i love my Swedish zuckerstand
ich kann die immer wiederholt Essen
vielleicht wenn man es auch noch
verschenkt also ich habe jetzt Glück
dass ich euch die in die Adventskalender
Verlosungen packe aber also ne schwierig
das ist scheiße
gemacht und ab dem ersten Türchen reißt
man es dann total hässlich kaputt das
muss ja auch im Wohnzimmer schön aus
stehen und stehen und weihnachtliche
Stimmung verbreiten und nicht
altpapiertonnenweibes geben und für 44
Euro würde ich mir eh nicht so viel
Zucker holen was haltet ihr von dem
Kalender ich bin wirklich so ein
bisschen hin und hergerissen er ist eine
nette Idee die Umsetzung gib diesem
Video unbedingt einen Daumen nach oben
um mich zu unterstützen und schreibt in
die Kommentare welche Adventskalender
ich dieses Jahr auch noch auspacken soll
es sind noch nicht so viel angekommen
wie ich bestellt habe was natürlich
daran liegt dass der Versand dann erst
im Oktober November dann losgeht aber
bis dahin kriegen wir uns schon voll mit
solchen Adventskalendern das macht auch
Spaß gut